après le président de la République il y
a deux mois et demi c'était au tour du
ministre de la Santé d'être au chevet du
centre hospitalier de vendôme
aujourd'hui François Braun est venu
etvoquer le plan d'accueil aux urgences
pendant la période estivale l'occasion
aussi de concrétiser une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron le transfert
administratif de la maternité de la
clinique du sacré-cœur au centre
hospitalier de vendôme
c'est confirmé Vendôme garde et gardera
sa maternité à la clinique du 5 heures
François Brown le ministre de la Santé
est venu ce matin dans les locaux du
centre hospitalier de la ville pour
évoquer le dossier maternité de Vendôme
bien présente toujours là bien entendu
avec les femmes qui peuvent y accoucher
sans inquiétude et maternité qui va
finaliser son transfert de
responsabilité à l'hôpital public tout
en restant bien sûr dans ses locaux la
maternité ne bouge pas mais se transfert
va se réaliser maintenant mi-septembre
un certain nombre de dossiers techniques
nécessité un peu plus de travail au
total 24 personnels de la clinique
pourront prendre le statut d'agent
hospitalier public ce maintien d'une
maternité c'est bien sûr une nécessité
pour le territoire oui il y avait
quelque chose à sauver parce que
effectivement on connaît tous et tous
les difficultés du groupe à la tête de
la clinique aujourd'hui et effectivement
il y avait besoin de sauver et de
garantir la pérennité de cette maternité
c'était fondamentale pour nous c'est une
évidence sur ce territoire il y a un
réel besoin on sait que le nombre
d'accouchements est important il va
continuer à augmenter mais on avait
besoin de cette pérennité plus de 500
enfants naissent chaque année avant
d'hommes la reprise en main par
l'hôpital public doit maintenant
rassurer les futurs parents